this is Startalk this one is from I love
it
James Brown that's that again so that
was a as heady Murphy said that's a
whole James Brown lyric right there so
this from James Brown to quote dr. Tyson
he's quoting you heavy elements are
forged in the cubicles of dying stars a
crucible so crucibles of dying stars but
did you miss read that or have you miss
right I misread that so what do we have
you for indeed I am but I'm only here
because I'm charming in other words to
get protons to stick together they need
high heat and pressures so why wasn't
there enough pressure to create anything
heavier than hydrogen and helium in
whatever started the Big Bang oh yeah
this guy has done some thinking here oh
I like it
mmm okay so good good one so at the
beginning of the universe he knows that
the conditions were just right to not
only Forge matter out of energy this is
where you get your protons that are the
nuclei of hydrogen hydrogen the simplest
element that's the one that was up in
the corner of the periodic table Opie
our table begins there right there right
there one proton the first step the
first step and a helium has two protons
and lithium has three protons and and
this goes on and on and on carbon has
six protons
everybody's got a unique number of
protons and that's the identity of the
element so here we start with hydrogen
we take protons slam them together we
make helium mm-hmm okay so why don't we
keep making other elements in the early
universe we do a little bit of lithium
is made trace amounts and that's because
the universe at that time was a little
depressed they said we need to listen
please make some of that some left yes
I'm a dad right so watch what happens
while the universe under high
temperatures could have been making
heavier elements it is also expanding
right it's becoming less dense and as
your density drops
the likelihood of particles colliding
goes down exactly it's the difference
between living in New York City and
living in rural Kansas your chances of
having an accident go way down when
you're in rural Kansas well the chances
of walking into someone that's what that
means okay right colliding collision
that's a collision of any kind right
principle back so so yes and so while
the universe is expanding matter is not
only becoming less stance it's also
cooling and so the speeds of these
particles drop that's it and so in fact
you can look at how much hydrogen and
and helium is in the universe in parts
of the universe that have not been
altered severely and go back and deduce
what those conditions must have been
uh-huh at the same time you can go back
and derive these from first principles
and those two knows two calculations
match up that's and so that's why we
have very high confidence in what was
going on in the early universe
nice yeah and where's it a star you make
your hydrogen you have your helium and
you just keep going up the chain and you
are hot you are dense this stuff doesn't
get less dense down there it gets even
more dense you're good good to go
see okay that's great yeah I said it
gets more doesn't it it's it's they're
contained whereas the universe is
expanding and cooling right that's the
different great question that is a great
car way to go James Brad